[Music]
so ice cube kevin hart and i decided to
go for a drive around hollywood and we
thought we'd do it using the new
ride-sharing app lift
yeah
how it works and and we we didn't warn
anybody just got the app i touched the
app the driver had no idea who he was
picking up
then once the driver picked us up we
quickly put little tiny cameras
throughout the car
and went on a ride
and here's what happened
all right right now i'm going to go on
my little lift app
we're going to get us a car and have
some fun request lift
i see look at all those cars right near
us
we need to go to the weed spot
immediately you have that look cube this
guy anthony i trust him look he's got
close cropped hair hey anthony uh do you
mind giving us a ride i got i'm here
with two pals
you think oh no time at all okay great
we'll see in a second
anthony five minutes
cube is this you do you like things to
happen right now like that man look i'm
not saying that i'm scared because i'm
not but this ain't safe
for some time right now and it looks
like we selling ass i mean
she's going to try to buy anyway we're
not selling any ass lady let's come over
here and try to buy any ass cause this
ain't where you gonna find it you ain't
selling ass over here
anthony yep there he is
hey what's with the mustache homie you
mind if we uh take a ride right now i
got kevin hart i got ice cube conan
o'brien here we take a little ride we
put some cameras in the car real fast
can we do that okay he's in
[Music]
hey man you know what a good weed spot
is you know what that is i i might have
a couple ideas
is this your own personal car yes cube
it is how do you feel about people
getting in funky and just funking it up
you had people start in here
excuse me excuse me having sex sex
no but going into great detail about
what it is they do sometimes have you
ever had to hose the car down the
interior of the car down afterwards
there was one time when one gentleman
vomited in the car so i didn't have to
who's sitting in that seat you are sir
how did you know how did you guys know
hey man have you ever been paid in sex
uh not to my knowledge would you take
sex as a payment yeah why not would you
have well i'm proposing to you
i'm just saying i'd save us as much as
thirty dollars you guys don't even have
to watch if you don't
have you ever got robbed uh no not yet
all right
you thought wrong jack okay this is how
we do it we get cars to pick us up we
say it's a comedy bit that's it and then
we take their
stop by the money man let's let's get a
photo or something
you know what i'll go i can get us some
uh 40s you got to teach me how to say it
though i say 40s but how do you say it
floaty
photo
i'm about to stop and get this photo you
want me to grab you one yeah man grab me
a photo and when you're getting him a 40
could you get me a 40. it's the same
thing
just because you can obviously make it a
different drink
it has fewer calories
and i want some snacks i want like a
chico stick hold it and i want some
starbursts you want a chico stick chico
sticky starburst starburst we want some
foaties
this is swisher sweets swisher sweets
what's a swisher sweet it's something
that cube knows about just get it
let me get this straight i'm just gonna
go on myself we need three foaties
phones we need some swisher sweet swiss
sweets we need
you need chico sticks what what's that
what's a chico just ask for it connor
why you've got to
know why just go get
hey don't oh and get us some lottery
tickets from lottery drinks yeah just in
case some scratches you got a number you
like no cody just get the ticket
white people got to be technical all the
time
hey look back to what i was saying cube
how do you feel about conan for real
conan is cool cool he's a cool cool cool
cool white boy his jeans be tight though
the dreams do be tight
i mean damn look like conan back pockets
touching right now
[Applause]
that's it
you guys cool with nutella just give it
to us
and i also got us this ghost of
girlfriend's past
that's all they had
wait wait a minute where's the brown
paper bag man you don't just get it out
of bro
you didn't say anything about a brown
paper bag we need a brown paper bag you
didn't say anything about a brown paper
bag
[Music]
normally in a car would be listed into
some tunes we can't do that right now
because anything that comes on the radio
we probably have to clear it and pay for
it and we can't do that
it's the conan no problem
all i'm doing is i'm gonna lay down a
beat that's all i need that'll simulate
us listen to some good tunes are you
okay with this
did you say that was not good it was
pretty terrible yeah it was pretty bad
anthony i've known you what 15 minutes
now yes sir and that's what i get that's
the kind of support i get here's the
kind of support you get
if you won't bust no rhymes
with my man o'brien he just looking in
the back he be lying in the car the
mustang straight rolled up ride the beat
corner laying down and hold up
huge we got a cop right here a couple
cops put
so what i did was bad i was staring
right at it
it gets all busted man hey you know what
you were on my side when we met anthony
and then five minutes into this suddenly
you're with these guys and everything i
do is stupid
obviously smart man you always take the
black guy outside whenever i'm done you
go to black
really how about if you're not sure the
white freckled guy is the cure
anthony you don't know where the drugs
are you know there might be a run in
canyon actually where all the hikers go
now we're getting somewhere now we're
getting started listen you don't tell
nobody you saw us on this mission we out
here trying to get some weed right now
do you like any of these girls oh i like
them all are you girls single i am
anthony this is when you ask for the
number this is amazing this is anthony
anthony put put put huge penis next to
him
that's how she don't know is you show
her
conan turn around all right we're not
looking but i'd like to pee
and you told me
shoulder
so how does it work how do we pay you
when this is over it's all done through
the app wait a minute this is on my
credit card yeah so i'm getting stuck
with the payment the full payment plus a
tip i'll give you a tip if you had shown
her the tip but you didn't hurt
you got hungry do you want a tweet yeah
give me what it's up to you guys what do
you want what do you like to get at
wendy's i get the spicy nuggets what do
you get cube uh i'll probably get a
double
how are you guys going to be if i get
the toasted flatbread asiago ranch
chicken club
no
i don't know
oh my friends call it
is it matt yeah it's matt
matt what's up man
hey what's going on we got his ass
locked down that's what's going on i
want to see your friend again you get
here with a bag full of money [ __ ]
head
[Applause]
yeah we got that pink mustache
yeah man you want to see your boy and
his legs again cause i cut his shirts
off
we're gonna cut his head off we're going
to cut his legs off and we're going to
put his head on the legs
you know what that means
that means that he's going to have to
kick
talk
what
i never got this one
all right let's get out all right hey i
need to show you how much you owe me
though about the run baby let's go man
we straight
i left my brown bag
[Applause]